yes by close of trading Friday no you
can't have more time you know the terms
you know the consequences Friday it is
that you have a good night mr. president
1080p check 60 frames per second check
super awesome hardcore hack and slash
action mega check yes DMC Devil May Cry
definitive edition takes an already
great game and turns everything time to
11 evany Harry miss you girls let's
start with the visuals this time
rendering at a stable 1080p 60 frames
per second say what you will about just
how much people actually notice frame
rate and resolution but for games that
value split-second timing those extra 30
frames are essential and make for a
smoother or responsive experience the
extra resolution also highlights DMC's
stylistic triumphs it's colorful
oversaturated look is not only visually
stunning in its new 1080p guys but also
strangely prescient of the direction
that later Xbox one and PlayStation 4
games would take that great one of the
best additions is the optional turbo
mode which boosts game speed by
substantial 20% it's not for the
faint-hearted but the additional speed
makes for furious and thoroughly
enjoyable combat there's also the
optional hardcore mode that rebalances
the game some of the changes included
suite style system that quickly
deteriorates increased enemy damage
adjusted parry and evade windows and a
shorter devil trigger with dante's
trifecta of light medium and heavy
weapons in tow as well as guns for range
shots spectacular combos fly off the
fingers far less effort than before
that's not to say things easier this
time around you will still need to put
in the effort in practice mode carefully
studying the command list in order to
graduate from simple button mashing but
it's worthwhile and before
long staccato stabbing motions are
replaced with elegant swipes dodges and
uppercuts that chain together for near
endless combos in the air and on the
ground
serious masochist can opt to turn on the
must style modifier which makes it so
that you can't damage enemies until
you've achieved an SL fire style ranking
by pulling off sweet combos stack all
the modes and modifiers together and the
game turns into a challenge worthy of
even the most skilled of hacking /
players fetch from Devil May Cry fans
can even choose to use manual lock-on
throughout which is a nice touch
annoyingly if you play through the game
before on an old console and have
already unlocked the harder difficulty
levels you have to play through the
easier ones again to get back to them
what remains unchanged in DMC is the
story but it's surpassed expectations
here not because it was ever bad but it
was always overshadowed by the stellar
combat playing through it again though
it's amazing to see just how ambitious
and at times rather clever it is let's
not forget that as a series Devil May
Cry didn't exactly set the world on fire
with its shot details of adolescent
fantasy but with DMC ninja theory
crafted a story with depth
mostly believable characters and an
ambitious assault on commercialism and
modern media they are enslaving mankind
asleep brainwashed
and helpless time has been kind DMC boss
battles - they're still terribly
formulaic making you learn of bosses
repetitive movements in order to land an
attack but they're seriously impressive
both visually and narrative Lee an early
encounter with the squishy succubus is a
treat not because of the basic
platforming required to defeat her but
because of the incredibly foul-mouthed
tirades and in volatile neon vomiting
is it all a case of style over substance
perhaps but boy what a style
I imagine there are still some people
out there put off by the direction that
Ninja Theory took with the emcee you
still haven't given the game a shot
because it's so drastically changed with
the series this does the game a huge
disservice DMC in its definitive form
isn't just a look of paint and a
technical upgrade it's a real twist on
an already impressive game making it
even more hardcore and insanely
difficult than ever before DMC Devil May
Cry definitive edition isn't just a
better version of DMC it's a bonafide
and slash classic
missed